[Music]
[Laughter]
this show is brought to you by the cash
app as you know cash app is the simplest
way to send and save money and now it's
the simplest way to try and grow your
money introducing cash app investing
unlike investing tools that only let you
buy entire shares of stock cash app lets
you instantly invest as little or as
much as you want this way when your
favorite company stock is just a little
too expensive you can still own a piece
with as little as $1 and because cash up
is directly connected with your bank
account there are no four to five day
waiting periods for inbound transfers so
you can start investing today brokerage
services are provided by cash app
investing the subsidiary of square and
member si PC and as always when you sign
up for cash up and use the promo code
Congrats not only will you instantly
receive $10 but cash up will also not
donate $10 to the trevor project an
amazing organization that provides
crisis intervention and suicide
prevention services to LGBTQ youth
across America download cash app from
the App Store or Google Play Store today
[Music]
what's up dude it's Chris D'Elia
congratulations episode 145 I got my in
cell right here butters with me sitting
on my lap and he's looking cute as [ __ ]
look at him dude the both got graphics
on our on our I got my shirt and he's
got it on his up on his bandana here
he's a stud dude butters is an in cell I
know you don't I know you don't get to
see him so much but butters is an in
cell and he's chilling and and and we
love him though and he's got a fat belly
you could hear it right there and he's
got bad breath but he's an insult so a
lot of insults probably have really bad
breath anyway let's look at some of the
[ __ ] what do you think butters we got we
got we got a November 1st of Foxwoods
Bethlehem Pennsylvania November 2nd it's
a religious Bethlehem then we're playing
Jerusalem just kidding Rochester New
York
November 3rd Royal Oak Michigan Detroit
Michigan got a few of these new Buffalo
Michigan Minneapolis some shootin my
neck Netflix special Tampa Florida
Melbourne Florida Hollywood Florida El
Paso Texas in Houston Texas coming up we
got two shows in there at the renovation
Music Center we're gonna be there we got
an early in the Late Show so grab your
tickets while you still can
there's only a few left on the Late Show
and we've got Peoria Illinois for some
reason we're going over to Peoria
Illinois at the Peoria Civic Center and
they weren't even creative enough to
make a name for their Civic Center and
just call it the city because it's pure
yeah and then we got Chicago Illinois
and December 31st and Chicago Illinois
don't we have a villain Oy on December
30th too but it's not on here one fire
so anyway that's what's up and dude how
was your [ __ ] Halloween how was your
Halloween hmm you see some hooks did you
see did you see extra skin did you see
that because Halloween we don't like we
don't like Halloween here at the
congratulations studios dude B you
always don't dresses someone else know
what the work with them
most annoying thing is when people say
that's it Halloween's over
[ __ ] Gabrielle Union one Halloween
with her outfit nobody wins Halloween I
don't like when any tell anytime someone
makes anything a competition I'm so not
like that if you want to compete you won
cool see you later I'll just be chilling
Elvis just be chilling with mice
americano and my insel butters Wow
[ __ ] check out this girl who dressed
as Billie Eilis she won Halloween all
right cool what'd she win nothin she
wasted a bunch of time doing makeup and
all that [ __ ] once am i I was gonna go
to my gym I couldn't even make it not
Halloween because I was busy but also
there was what do you call it everyone's
gonna be [ __ ] dressed up like all the
trainers and [ __ ] you hear butters
butters do you have something you want
to say say something
sniffing animal abuse so uh yeah but
yeah you didn't win huh let's see who
won Halloween let's just look up on
Twitter who won Halloween this [ __ ] is
what was I think I was thinking about
how you winning Halloween is like what
do you call it when people say what the
[ __ ] is this dude win Halloween
Halloween how come my Twitter isn't
signed in look at this Ciarra is it
Ciara and Russell Wilson's Beyonce and
jay-z costumes win Halloween win
Halloween cancelled all right do it dude
that's so annoying that's like when
people beat the whole win I don't like
when people get these look make up your
own coin terms dude did they just
dressed up like the [ __ ] people
that's not winning that's a losing you
did all that [ __ ] Mario Lopez's kids win
Halloween with Saved by the Bell
the Johnsons win Halloween
look at all these people who won
Halloween how could everybody win
Halloween
these are the classic top 10 Halloween
costumes Ghostbusters women's
Ghostbusters this according to savant
mag Where's Waldo
of course rue was Ruby's woman's
despicable Despicable Me yeah
Star Wars okay Wonder Woman okay Suicide
Squad oh man there's so many people were
for harlech Harley Quinn
I mean Deadpool you know no II nobody
did that pool harambe well what year is
this from [ __ ] [ __ ] on date number
one is her Robin no one's Horsehead mask
since last minute [ __ ] thing um
anyway I'm putting butters down he's fat
as [ __ ] I'm putting him down see you
butters yay
everyone almost died in LA last week too
because of the fires dude it's amazing
how many fires there just are gonna be
forever man
when I was growing up there weren't many
fires now so many fires is it global
warming I don't know what it is am i a
scientist no I'm not a scientist but why
do know is sometimes when I breathe in
there's ashes dude I was running uh
doing sprints the other day that's how I
keep it real tight from my muhfuckin
midsection do you know do you know I
mean that's how I keep the [ __ ]
double the double black diamond ski
slopes on my [ __ ] in my midsection
here
that's how if somebody if anyone wants
to a [ __ ] advanced ski just start up
my nipples and go down to the groin area
you're gonna have a tough time skiing
like that keep your knees [ __ ]
buckling though you know what I mean
don't make sure they don't don't strain
them out you'll [ __ ] it means nothing
so what was I saying about the the fires
all yes so I was doing sprints and I do
it outside my house cuz it's a [ __ ]
it's a what do you call it a an incline
and I was doing it with my buddy at my
opener one of my openers mark and it was
so hard for some reason we couldn't
breathe and then we
like what's going on and he was like oh
what's going on welcome I couldn't
breathe you know cuz he's Irish
and then like later on he texted me all
the the it's everything's on fire [ __ ]
and I was like what do you mean why [ __ ]
her and he was like that's why we
couldn't breathe I was like oh yeah I
had so much ash in me I should I it's I
should have become a superhero that's I
how [ __ ] lazy are some of the
superheroes though it was like like
Spider Man dude that's so lazy that he
got bit by a radioactive spider alright
bro come on man some wouldn't happen we
know I know none of it would happen but
like at least a little bit try harder
you know this [ __ ] is so [ __ ] 40s he
bit by a spider that's why I was already
two actors fight and then he turned into
spider-man now yes now we can sling webs
out of his wrists and his spidey sense
or like [ __ ] that should be my soup
that I breathed in a bunch of [ __ ]
ash and now I'm just
I have no I'm fired but now I'm fired
breathing dragon I'm [ __ ] whatever
Brian counts as he's man dragon ah so
yeah the fires were [ __ ] crazy man a
lot of my friends had to evacuate I feel
really badly man my heart goes out to
them and also [ __ ] the fire men dude
that are just imagine being a fireman
like for real
imagine going into fire and putting it
out that's so unbelievable how about
when people say those are the real
superheroes I don't I I don't know about
this whole like like like anything like
people love to blow [ __ ] out of
proportion like like dude what those
people are doing firemen are the utmost
heroic [ __ ] but being a hero I've always
thought this being a hero is like
amazing you know like if you save
somebody from a [ __ ] blazing car
wreck or they're about to fall into a
volcano and you catch their hand and
they're like don't let go and you're
like I won't and then you pull them out
as the volcano's exploding and then you
just tumble down the volcano
and then you to safety you know if
you're a [ __ ] hero
you're a hero and that's the best and
when you're a hero that's the top when
somebody says yeah those are the real
superheroes that's a superhero
no it diminishes it to me I like hero
being the top [ __ ] okay don't say
superhero because then you're
diminishing it this is how I've always
felt and of course it doesn't matter at
all just like everything in the [ __ ]
congratulations podcast but we talked
about the real hard-hitting issues if
you know deep if there's a [ __ ] world
under the world and that's what we're
exposing here at congratulations okay
when you say you're a superhero you're
diminishing
the [ __ ] heroes being a hero is the
[ __ ] it's like what was I just thinking
and I lost it cuz I need to drink ginkgo
biloba the [ __ ] was it what the [ __ ] was
it it was Oh when people say like here's
another one here's another example that
I don't like when somebody says a killer
is a monster I dude it drives me nuts
it's not a monster that makes people
take that makes people that puts people
with real mental issues at arm's length
and it makes us think that it's not a
human when it is a human dude and it's a
human with real [ __ ] mental issues
and when they say Ted Bundy was a
monster that makes it so it's harder for
us to figure out why it happens to
somebody when if we figure out why it
happens to somebody who could stop
[ __ ] people from murdering people and
eating them if you want people to stop
eating people stop calling them monsters
step one step one call him a person with
a mental issue anyway there were a bunch
of fires and I didn't become a [ __ ]
superhero even though it would have been
nice man I remember when I was a kid I
used
waste some [ __ ] like that would happen
to me I used to just wish some [ __ ] like
that would happen to me like like man
maybe if I [ __ ] maybe if some you
know squirrel bit me it would just be
easier for me to climb trees you know I
remember thinking in my dumb kid brain
that maybe that could happen I remember
one time I think I told us on the
podcast before but like I had hi-c mime
that grape hi-c it spilled all over my
face and I thought it was purple on my
face and I thought it looked badass and
I thought that [ __ ] I thought that and
the chicks and I thought if the chicks
would have noticed it I looked like a
punk rocker and then they were like and
then I and then I and then nobody was
saying I look like a punk rocker though
and I was like but it's purple on my
face had great bye I see and I was like
maybe it's not purple enough and I left
out my face I didn't wipe it off and was
getting really sticky and I was like his
maker break don't nobody said anything I
was gonna ask him and I asked one chick
I think her name was Aaron but I was
like hey Aaron is it purple on my face
at all and she was like no and I was
like oh and I just wiped it off I had to
get I had to get a [ __ ] wet towel on
it and wipe it off cuz it was so sticky
I kept hi-c on my face for like [ __ ]
20 minutes as a seven-year-old what a
[ __ ] you know uh how what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] anyway dude I'm a nap time in
kindergarten number [ __ ] naptime
dude I I hated naptime dude I was always
too old for nap time we were in
kindergarten and mrs. [ __ ] how do I
forget her name
mrs. Antoine wow she was the best
kindergarten teacher and she and she
would we had naptime she's like alright
class time for nap time I'd be like aw
come on dude my mom would give me a
blanket and she'd be like here's for nap
time and I would always sit I would
always lay down dude I would never sleep
bro they had naptime don't have school
if you're gonna have a naptime in it
wait till the kids are a little bit
older and then send them to school I
we had naptime and we would we would lay
down and I would always be like and I
would always be like hey yo what's up I
would I remember talking to [ __ ]
Justin McKinnon by the way who was the
guy in the last episode but I was said
Jordan with the slam that Justin
McKinnon I would talk to him through the
Cubbies I'll be like hey man what's up
and and then [ __ ] Sumatra will be
like his nap time shot the [ __ ]
Sumatra was Sumatra was [ __ ] did she
stole an answer from me once when I was
in kindergarten dude she was like no I
wasn't you know this right like second
grade but she was like she was like the
teacher was asking questions and I said
it out loud like under my breath and
then she raised her hand and said the
answer and and I was like what the [ __ ]
you stole her from me and she said well
don't say your answers out loud of you
ain't gonna raise your hand and I was
like life lesson do it life lesson from
Sumatra dude ha ha ha ha life lesson
from Sumatra man she straight up turned
around and said then don't be saying you
[ __ ] out loud if you and wanted [ __ ]
raise your hand
the two girls together
nothing is my fault dude nothing is my
fault
they're too close together I didn't put
them there one fire did that's why he's
one fire and the story dude you know
butters shut the [ __ ] up you're an insel
dude butters been doing this [ __ ] just
like wow look you hear him
shut the [ __ ] up dude you got dogs
they're in sales doll dogs are in sales
butters had sex once butters has a kid
butters has two kids one time I was I
would hang out with this chick and we
were we were at my home and this is so
long ago we're at my hat my up while my
apartment and we were hanging out and we
look
/ and butters was stuck in her dog you
ever see [ __ ] you know dogs penises
they're like [ __ ] grappling hooks
they go in and then they [ __ ] swell
up and they can't get out that that
pretty much ensures insemination and I
know this and so and so they were
[ __ ] and then and then and then his
penis got caught and I look over and I
went what the [ __ ] and she was like oh
my god what the [ __ ] it I tried to grab
butters out of the other dog and you're
not supposed to do that butters was so
like the [ __ ] is going on dude so he's
not really an insult cuz he did [ __ ] and
he has two kids dude he's two dog kids
she gave one away and another one I
don't know what maybe she still has Ivan
I mean I haven't talked to her in
[ __ ] years but butters has two
[ __ ] sons or something butters is a
[ __ ] dude butters is gangster dude he
[ __ ] one time I was in science class
and they were talking about and they
were talking about how like SEC we're
talking about sex and procreation and I
was like how come sex feels so good
though and she was like well they had to
make it feel good so we would do it and
we would populate the world and then I
honestly think about that every three
weeks so that's cool dude this show is
no I already did that when you need
Rhett look post mates you guys know
about post mates cuz you don't live
under a rock but if you don't you got to
know about post mates it's the best I
use post mates last night and I got a
whole bunch of food it all it was
beautiful when you need red wine at 4
p.m. sushi at 9 p.m. a breakfast burrito
at 8 a.m.
ibuprofen at 10 at 10 a.m. or if you're
like me and you need all the food at 3
a.m. post made it post mates is your
personal food delivery grocery delivery
whatever kind of delivery service all
year round anything you're craving post
a nice can deliver the largest on demand
network in the US and offer delivery
from all the restaurants grocery and
convenience why am I even talking about
this how do you not know what post plate
says get it 24 hours a day 365 days a
year
post plates will bring it bring you what
you need within the hour there's no
trips to the store you got it baby you
don't even know have to even now you
need to know where the store is you just
click on it it's so easy to navigate
download the app for iOS or Android for
free browse local restaurants and
businesses and track your delivery in
real time for a limited time Post Bates
is giving our listeners $100 of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days to
start your free deliveries download the
app and use code Congrats that's code
congrats for $100 a free delivery credit
for your first 7 days when you download
the postmates postmates sound anything
you need anytime you need it post made
it downloaded post Waits and save with
code Congrats bro let me talk to you
about my sip my favorite Sox stance
have you ever noticed that you're seeing
or hearing a bunch of ads for socks just
a few years ago no one cared about socks
they didn't talk about them so why so
much noise about something that we never
used to care about because one brand
absolutely changed again when it comes
to socks I'm wearing them right now the
brand's creativity design and quality
was so incredible that ignited a
movement around a piece of apparel no
one had ever paid attention to before
it's true man
I got hooked on this dance train and I
love him but they brought out but but
stands brought out a bunch of wannabe
sucked it's like when Quentin Tarantino
made the movies and they were so dope
and then everyone started making movies
like quitting Tarantino and the dialogue
was just atrocious these are the Quentin
Tarantino socks of socks okay it's
honestly incredible design and comfort
with unmatched durability everyday
casual styles like and and also they
have a performance and athletic socks
the dodge designs are awesome I have so
many different ones love them I really
don't want to put anything else on my
feet ever again there's a reason to
dance change sock game forever and I
want you to try them for yourself okay
be cool like me that's why my listeners
can get a free pair of socks with
purchase at Stan's calm / Congrats that
Stan's calm / Congrats because if
they're not Stan's they're not socks
because of the stocks
dude if there was ever a [ __ ] reason
like uh we know here at congratulations
if you're part of this cult and if you
[ __ ] understand that one day we will
be in a log cabin if we one day we'll be
in a in the high grass sharing ideas uh
that we're not you know we try to limit
the [ __ ] co2 [ __ ] as much as we can
but these gender-reveal things are
getting out of control okay somebody
[ __ ] died because there was a
gender-reveal explosion okay somebody
died because there was a gender reveal
let's read about this real reveal
explosion oh my God look at this look at
this explosion at gender reveal party
kills woman officials say it's always
officials say family members at the
party were expectant parents where
expectant parents were announcing the
sex of their baby in a Verna created a
pipe bomb I mean Jesus that killed a
woman in Iowa Jesus I mean a woman in
Iowa died during a gender-reveal
announcement on Saturday after flying
debris from an explosion from what
amounted to a homemade pipe bomb struck
her Jesus the woman died instantly after
she was struck in the head by a piece of
metal from a device that was intended
Jesus man this article's brutal was I
mean was it a boy or a girl to at least
tell us
oh my god a hole had been drilled in the
side for a fuse a piece of wood was
placed on top of gunpowder Oh bad idea
and colored powder was placed on top of
the board
tape was enrapt over the top of the
middle metal tubing inadvertently
creating a pipe bomb
I mean 45 feet from the device the
projectile that struck her continued 144
yards farther through the air and landed
in a field oh man you know what man
that's so sad
god oh there's another one here in
Australia a car that begins slowly
expelling blue smoke to announce the
gender of a baby burst into flames
the driver who jumped out of the vehicle
was convicted of dangerous operation of
a car
Australians dude I've got an idea
let's put blue smoke in the exhaust well
don't you think this may be a little bit
of a dangerous operation yeah it doesn't
matter though because if I can put it in
there
and then the blue smoke will come out of
the back of the [ __ ] thing everyone
will be like it's a boy right then I'll
be [ __ ] all exciting is it worth it
though well yeah it's worth it right
because it'll be like it's a boy and
then I'll pull over and they'll be like
oh my god yeah and we'll all get like a
hug you know the belittle the blue smoke
around it but great for Instagram yeah
well what if the car catches fire it's
not gonna catch fire might is [ __ ] I
want to cook for it jump it it's a boy
for [ __ ] sake I'll just tell ya it's a
[ __ ] boy open up goddamn it tacking
round I you know they were in one of
those [ __ ] [ __ ] cars that are
like half trucks
cars get out get out it's a boy I'll
just tell you get out it's play smart
you can say get the [ __ ] out of the cab
get out dude just don't do a
gender-reveal looks [ __ ] thing just
say hey it's a boy or get a [ __ ]
thing and be like there's is a boy look
that I got a boy thing here's a onesie I
just anything for Instagram is so so
stupid how about the [ __ ] balloon
that flew away and the guy was so [ __ ]
trying to catch it dude the blew the
balloon [ __ ] flew away and he was
lying they were trying to bat it and it
[ __ ] flew away and the guy tried to
grab and he fell over the fence trying
to get it hey guy let it go just say boy
hey dude
don't die just let it go turn to your
wife and say boy these companies dude
that [ __ ] do it all together and
they're like we know the gender and we
put it in the cake eat the cake and they
slice the cake and it's pink it's like
such a [ __ ] why are you making it
harder to have a baby hey having a
baby's already real hard gender-reveal
goes hilariously wrong watched till the
end here's the other thing two videos
are always one minute long and it says
watch to the end dude I got the time man
it's one minute long oh wow this guy's
hilarious this guy looks like you will
play [ __ ] baseball in 1998 look at
him wow dude he fancies himself an
athlete look he tries to run he tries to
jump the fence and [ __ ] falls and all
the kids are running after it
wow dude man
don't do gender of is anything for
Instagram don't do those things that's
the thing everything became such a show
now everything became such a show that's
why everyone's showing the [ __ ] look
dude titties were rampant and Halloween
and now titties are a [ __ ] pandemic
because of Instagram I liked titties hey
dude I liked titties titties were all
gravy man
titties and midsections and [ __ ] and
thighs I was a red-blooded American male
Instagram made me hate titties bro how
you gonna make me hate teddies hey gonna
make me roll my eyes at Teddy's I was a
red-blooded American male up until an
Instagram now I'm a [ __ ] old man
robot Instagram hey go make me hate
titties so many titties dude follow me
alright alright dude walking into a
party alright okay we get it
how much what
how much money for me to burst inside
you what do you mean what do you mean
dude titties [ __ ] suck dude you know
I'm playing titties red you know playing
dude titties [ __ ] rip and that crazy
how dumb are guys when they see titties
you know how dumb guys are this is how
dumb guys are now I'm gonna be
straight-up honest with you guys I don't
really watch porn okay your boy likes to
use his mind I don't really watch porn
that much not saying I don't but here's
how dumb guys are when you [ __ ] go to
like whatever it is pornhub or X videos
or [ __ ] whatever the hell it is I'm
looking at it right now
Wow okay you see all the videos you see
the thumbnails you pick the one you like
and you click on it and you look and you
start looking at titties all right then
they show other thumbnails under that
video and the videos already popping
you're already where you are you [ __ ]
eatin my [ __ ] you understand
you're doing what you set out to do you
start the porns you watch the porns you
[ __ ] watching this [ __ ] and you're in
it and you got a [ __ ] thing going
you're you're you
dick starting to bracket kick kack kack
right your dicks starting to [ __ ]
breka kakakaka you know what I mean you
got your diving board all set up your
diving boards all set up dude now it's
illegal to have a diving board nowadays
in LA but your diving boards all set up
okay you got your caution [ __ ] [ __ ]
up it says caution
be careful dive in anyway so you're
watching the video this how dumb I am
this how dumb guys are you start looking
at the other thumbnails and you'll be
like oh but what about that one when
you're already doing what you want
that's how dumb guys are you're like ah
but what about the other one that chick
is cool about the way the positions are
another one looks pretty cool then you
click on that one and then you [ __ ]
start watching that one and then I got
more thumbnails and then you're watching
that one you know what I mean you ever
been having sex and you're like yeah but
what else is going on huh that's the
goal you're watching porn and you turn
into a [ __ ] 90s comic yeah so what
else is going on in the world
let's click these other thumbnails
anyway what else going on in the news
click this one oh yeah anyway what else
is going on yeah what else is going on
in the news oh yeah cool I told you the
time I [ __ ] went into Starbucks and I
had been watching porn earlier and I
open up the computer and I [ __ ] was
right at the part where the girl was
like oh yeah and I closed the [ __ ]
laptop dude that's the hottest part of
porn is when the girl is like so in it
and she's just you could I don't like
all the [ __ ] when the porn is like when
the girls like oh yeah give it to me
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh you
like that like dude relax what is this
[ __ ] Riverdance
stop trying the show the show hey hey
sweetheart when you're having sex and
you're like and the girls oh yeah oh
yeah
hey sweetheart are they
credits at the end of this whenever I
would have sex whenever I would do that
when I used to have sex and stuff like
with like chicks and I would do it and
then and then they'd be like oh yeah and
I would be like hey hey I would stop and
I'd be like who's producing this and
she'd say what and I'd say well this is
ghost Protocol and she said what do you
mean and I say well this is ghost
Protocol starring Tom Cruise with the
way you're acting she said I don't get
it and I'd say you're not part of
[ __ ] you're not part of the spine
yeah do it real man sex is real life so
why [ __ ] gloss it up bro
that's like that contour [ __ ] that
people wear you know whether you're a
guy or a girl you contour your face man
what is this Kabuki theater hey who's
producing it when you see someone with
contour hey but who's producing this
what well you're in a movie what that
would be so hilarious to walk up to a
chick who had such hard contour on and
you just say hey who is producing what
it would say well we're on set this is
what do you mean this is Starbucks well
where are the cameras sweetheart what do
you mean what do you mean what I what do
I mean you've got makeup for a movie on
wow dude you'd be canceled
you'd be canceled she would pretend like
she was a victim and you'd be canceled
it's like that [ __ ] with the [ __ ]
Mike Michael che Michael che with the
SNL when they tried to [ __ ] when he
made the joke about Kanye West and it
was all okay everything was okay until
he mentioned [ __ ] Caitlyn Jenner and
then everyone went nuts about it oh dude
it's legitimately a good joke when
Michael che was like he was saying like
wow Kanye West is a white lady now
because he's like [ __ ] into whatever
saying he was into fashion voting for
Trump and and he's like complains about
whatever the [ __ ] the joke was and he
was like he turned into an old white
lady and then it showed a picture of
Caitlyn Jenner and it was like by the
way I remember another guy who moved to
Calabasas and that was where the joke
stopped and it was like okay Bruce
Jenner turned into a [ __ ] old old
white lady as well and that's a [ __ ]
funny joke whatever you know it whatever
or not you think it's funny it's a joke
and there was this [ __ ] article dude
that came out on was it Indy wire I
don't wanna get this wrong actually what
was it it was on India in the wire here
it is yeah India wire saronite live
Michael chase Caitlyn Jenner joke wasn't
funny it was hate speech what hey are
you alright
writer dude hate speech imagine SNL
doing hate speech you want to be a
[ __ ] victim or what some people they
just want to be victims I swear to God
look at this over the week this was so
funny over the weekend sir Night Live
head writer Michael che told a joke at
the by the way Michael chase [ __ ]
hilarious
fan of Michael che nice guy loved the
dude told the joke at the expense of
Caitlyn Jenner that the joke totally
bombed did not seem to bother headstrong
comedian who giggled along with co-host
chick Colin Jost by the way oh there's
another guy who's [ __ ] awesome Colin
Jost such a nice guy
and [ __ ] hilarious didn't really bomb
the joke didn't bomb also even if it did
who cares
there's not the first time chance come
under scrutiny whatever it that's
because he's a [ __ ] talented comedian
at any time the comedian comes under
scrutiny
straight male comedians using
transgender people as a punchline bag
for their unfunny jokes chase so-called
joke I love this dude the writer calls
it a
so-called joke what do you know about
jokes who knows more about jokes you or
Michael Chang who does more my jokes you
or the head writer of SNL he said the
singer was turning into an old white
lady he elaborated I mean he used to be
one of the coolest black dudes on words
now he's showing up at events at
sweatpants orthopedic sneakers and
listening Kenny G that was the joke is
funnier than what I said and trying to
get black people to like from funny how
long before this guy named chases named
Kathy funny ticking on his joke the joke
is fine even mildly funny if Jay had
stopped there would have been a
perfectly acceptable quip that didn't
necessarily even reference trans people
much less in a disrespectful way but she
had to go and bring Caitlyn Jenner into
it now you'd think that I'm crazy but
about five years ago there was a fellow
named Bruce Jenner and he moved to
Calabasas there you go that was the
thing in in one short-sighted che
managed che manages to use the word
fella the incorrect pronoun and Jenner's
previous name okay but he was a guy
right he miss genders her dead names her
and actively calls her a word that is
safe to assume she would never use to
describe herself k as a refresher saqqaq
the writer as a refresher using a trans
person's birth name is referred to as
dead naming and is considered an act of
violence okay dude it's it's okay you
know you're gonna be like your your
that's not an act of violence
all right that's that's just somebody
saying some [ __ ] as a joke on Sarah not
life that's not an act of violence and
as a matter of fact is even what's an
act of violence is is a threat an act of
violence is somebody saying like hey I'm
gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] you up is that an act
of violence or is an act of violence
like striking someone I don't know what
do you think even saying saying
something is not an act of violence
I mean it can incite an act of violence
maybe I don't see how it is maybe I'm
wrong I'm a [ __ ] idiot when it comes
to this [ __ ] and definitely talking out
of my ass but holy [ __ ] that [ __ ] made
me laugh when I read that part like if
you want to be included if you want to
be if inclusion is real and you want to
be accepted then guess what dude
you get jokes coming your way if you
want to be included here come the jokes
dude make fun of me all day long a lot
of these people and this is not this is
this is the victims thing has gone out
of control dude
there are real victims out there that
have been through real [ __ ] it's like
don't take don't [ __ ] take that from
them man it sucks dude also that [ __ ]
these articles no joke or what guna is
these articles are what's gonna get
Trump elected again that's what's gonna
get Trump elected again a hundred
percent the two things that Trump are
gonna get is gonna get Trump elected
again and he's gonna get elected again
these are the two things that are gonna
get him elected again articles like that
tweets and [ __ ] like that and also the
horrible democratic [ __ ] choices the
only guys that can win I think are
either Warren but I don't I actually
don't think she can win and Budaj edge
but Budaj edge will not be the one that
is picked so
four more years I'd vote for a Buddha
judge in a [ __ ] heartbeat but he
won't be won't be he won't be picked as
the nominee and that sucks I would love
to see I would love to see him as a
president just a level-headed guy you
know I would love to see a level-headed
guy I'd love to see a guy that doesn't
tweet every day about crazy [ __ ] say
what you want about [ __ ] Trump or
whatever the [ __ ] and but yeah I you
know
Trump is hilarious man it's it's too bad
that I'm worried if somebody picked I'm
more what I'm actually worried about is
I'm not worried about cuz I'd only gonna
happen but like if somebody picks if
another guy gets in office and it's not
Trump that I mean Trump made it go one
way so far that if we pick somebody like
Bernie or Warren even like that ripple
just open way way more and then we're
and then and then it'll divide the
country even harder and then an actual
war will live or will come out will
start that's what I'm worried about
I just you need someone level-headed man
you you need someone that's just gonna
look at you can't pick someone that's
two left now because it'll [ __ ] it'll be
really [ __ ] interesting to see what
the [ __ ] happens I hate talking about
politics I really [ __ ] hate it so I'm
not gonna do it here's an ad break
intersect announcing intersect festival
by AWS where music art and technology
converged taking place December 6th and
7th at the Las Vegas festival grounds
right on the Vegas Strip intersect is
presented by Amazon Web Services born
out of the massive after-party for the
re-invent conference now open to the
public for the first time ever
featuring Foo Fighters you ever heard of
them Anders impact ever heard of them
Kacey Musgraves back flying loads ever
heard of them Leon bridges her spoon
Jamie xx ever heard of them Thundercat
churches Brandi Karla ever heard of them
though yo yo
look Rolling Stone says the festival has
booked headliners to rival that of
Coachella and lined up enough tech
projects to bill itself as a mini South
by Southwest
dude intersect isn't just a music
festival in addition to a diverse lineup
of more than 30 music acts this
immersive experience features
cutting-edge digital art and an
interactive experience like a
post-apocalyptic dodgeball stadium a
video arcade and more sounds fun for a
limited time
congratulations listeners can save $10
on a two-day general admission tickets
to intersect by going to intersect fest
comm and entering offer code congrats to
unlock the deal that's intersect fest
calm and promo code congrats to save
yourself some cash and be a part of this
incredible experience feels I love that
name baby's Fields is a better way to
feel better and now that's hobbies' our
premium CBD from Fields will keep your
head clear and help you feel your best
CBD has been proven to greatly reduce
anxiety pain and sleeplessness look dude
do I have to even say that do you live
under a rock you know that by now
navigating the world of CBD can be
complicated at fields we look to make
the process as simple as possible so you
can start feeling better sooner new to
CBD fields offers a free CBD hotline and
tech support to help guide you through
the discovery process know CBD is right
for you
feels hassle free membership program is
guaranteed to help you feel your best
month after month or your money back
it's that simple dude I like that name
feels that's a killer company man easy
to take place a few drops of feels under
your tongue and feel the difference but
within minutes do it plus you get to be
cool like that you get to go open up the
time you let's go bluie and then you got
to sit back and just be like
do you know what I mean that's dope dude
like you're some evil villain just go
feel better naturally it's natural feels
works naturally to help you feel better
there's no high hangover or addiction
feels has one fire feeling is best every
day and it can help you to one fires my
producer and he is loving it become a
member today by going to feels calm /
congrats and you'll get 50% off your
first order with free shipping that's f
e ALS dot-com / Congrats don't forget
there's an A in there to become a member
and get 50% off automatically taken off
your first order with free shipping
feels calm / congrats congratulations is
brought to you by cash app the official
app of the log cabin yeah dude
so it's a weird thing about this whole I
feel like some people now I'm not
talking about just so you know I'm not
talking about [ __ ] trans anymore I'm
not talking about anything I'm just
talking about the victimhood and people
who a lot of people are calling victim
when you're not a victim or are playing
the victim a lot of people they don't
want these people you know they don't
want to be equal they want superiority
you know because it's a natural it's a
natural to be one to want to be superior
dude [ __ ] it's awesome to be superior
in every single way when I go on stage I
want to be some of the people's favorite
comedian that's it then I check myself
and I'm like you know what I'm not for
everybody not everybody's for everybody
that's what makes comedy good I hope
that [ __ ] people also like Theo von
I don't know it's a [ __ ] weird world
we live in case a point [ __ ] Jeffrey
Epstein was [ __ ] killed for sure
didn't need his brother looking into it
to know that didn't his brother look
into it and found out like there was
like it was more consistent with
homicide than it and the [ __ ] Rogen's
been reposting the funniest [ __ ] [ __ ]
about Jeffrey Epstein
Jeremy was Jeffrey Epstein yeah the last
one killed me this one the bar the baby
roost the baby Russa is a wild pig whose
tusks can grow so long they curve
backwards ultimately impaling their
skulls and accidentally killing them
unlike Jeffrey Epstein who was killed on
purpose um oh wait just opened more
seats in Florida okay that's cool I
gotta tell my opener okay hold on it's
just so annoying let me just tell you
what's going on here yes just opened
tell them to get tix now only 450 opened
so I sold out in the what do you call it
Florida Hollywood Florida and they
opened more seats and my opener Mike is
from Florida and he's always like oh I
got a lot of comps and I'm like bro he's
like can I get like 20 comps and you
don't understand like that's like
hundreds and hundreds of dollars for me
like if I give him 20 comps and also no
unit I mean like bags doesn't matter of
course
no dents I mean I looked for dents in my
bank account the other day I saw zero
and still no it is sin I mean I had a
chain made from a jeweler but still no
right right if it what I'm saying
so also people who ask for tickets like
go [ __ ] yourself man like it's it's fun
it's actually fine if I know you kind of
and you're like hey can I get like two
tickets yeah I know people it's not
about the money I get it people like to
feel hooked up they like to feel special
all right cool but also like if you're
[ __ ] 40 and like your buddy is like
doing a show and you make a good living
like just [ __ ] buy the tickets man
like buy the tickets or at least say
like or at least offer you know I'm hey
man I'm happy to pay I really want to
come see you you know even that even
though it's like the guy's gonna say now
just do it I think I hit up Luis Capaldi
for [ __ ] tickets though I feel bad
not saying that I don't remember if I
did that or not but uh or no makeup but
I don't remember if I tore the primer or
not but anyway dude tell Andrew
one it [ __ ] idiot on StubHub but I
doubt that's true that's true Mike is
saying and idiot on StubHub bought one
thousand that's not true
tickets that's not true right I mean do
it mike is so dumb dude that's not true
it's sold out like what it sold out bro
like what anyway um so that's what's up
oh cool got a lot of mucus uh anyway
dude the group text is going off and
Michael anoche set a bunch of stuff and
then he said what the heck and then he
said why is no one saying anything put a
[ __ ] put a [ __ ] why is no one saying
anything there's five of us bro how
about when you're in a group chat let me
tell you I bet chicks are not like this
dudes are like this and it's annoying
we'll be in a group chat and [ __ ]
there's like three guys talking and then
you forget two other guys are even in it
cuz they never talk dude there's two
dudes in this group chat that never
[ __ ] talk man
get talking man get [ __ ] talking
it's called Coffee Bean and Tea Leaf
crew who is it it's [ __ ] mark Hayes
Michael Inoki Craig Conan who never says
a [ __ ] word cuz he texts like this
with one finger bro oh my god he takes
one finger look at Mike's texting me a
[ __ ] thing here look look at this was
this the way he's [ __ ] Mike sending
me something and I'm pissed already
oh look look look look I text him I and
I texted my agent here uh Mike is saying
an idiot on StubHub bought a thousand
two hundred tickets tickets that's not
true right he said well considering
there's only sixty three sixty three
tickets on StubHub than how also it
would have been flagged if one person
bought 1200 seats where is he getting
this info this is what I write back well
you see mike is [ __ ] and in caps very
dumb so I don't know I don't know now we
group text them together here's how we
do it do it
Andrew Russell Michael anoche I had
Michael anoche Michael anoche just a day
of and day in my life hey Mike now I
write this you're dumb huh to the agent
there you go
off to the races hey Mike you're dumb
huh I love being a guy chicks don't do
this [ __ ] I love being a guy what was I
gonna text the other day oh I got a
buddy that's got no clue with chicks man
he's zeroed in on a chick the other day
who has a boyfriend by the way 40
minutes zeroed in to her like a [ __ ]
drunk brent morin just zeroed in wasn't
brent morin zeroed in on a girl for 40
minutes and started talking to her so
close dude and afterwards he was like so
i guess she likes me and i was like bro
that's not good
that's not good dude listen to me guys
listen to me in cells alright take it
from your boy if you're talking to a
girl for 40 minutes
you best be at dinner Sola with her if
you're monopolizing a girl's time in in
in a public setting with a bunch of
people
for 40 minutes in between her legs
Sahara if you pop in and out like you're
a boxer if you're stinging like a bee
floating like a butterfly pat-pat-pat
and you talk to someone else pat pat pat
talking to someone else in between her
legs
Waterfalls okay that's the thing dude
you want to [ __ ] get some you don't
monopolize a girl's time in 48 for 40
minutes in a public setting you don't do
that dude especially while she's working
dude that's not how it works bro Sahara
all good
Sahara all right now if you pop in and
out like you're the [ __ ] neighbor
from the home-improvement if she can't
really see ya if the fence is up above
your face and you got a fisherman's hat
on and it's covering your forehead and
the only thing you could see are your
eyes then all of a sudden who's that guy
pop pop pop it in and out
[Music]
trickling down the thighs whitney's you
understand if you pop in and out in a
conversation if you're productive to
that that day yeah that's what happens I
huh yeah I know a guy who does happen it
that that that that oh it's funny too
oh yeah yeah you know I've been time on
to but after that that talk to you later
gonna go spend some time with my boys
then all of a sudden
whoopsie-daisy wet knees but if you're
on then but come on boys I'm gonna bloom
in store for 40 minutes and she's yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
then tumbleweed City this is my friend
talking to a girl for 40 minutes this is
my friend this is my friend [ __ ]
talking to a chick a [ __ ] yeah timing it
is so bad that's okay Tom this is my
friend target Oh chick
[Laughter]
is watching from police this is actually
the most beautiful thing I've ever seen
a music just so many tumbleweed some
ways in this family's watching it kids
are laughing [ __ ] yeah dude wow that
what's a better [ __ ] sound than that
kid laughing what is my buddy talking
about Jim this is my buddy talking to a
check for 40 minutes
that's him that's him talking to a chick
doing that that's my buddy that's my
buddy talking to a chick and this
tumblin tumbleweeds and this is me
talking to a chick [ __ ] popping in
and out dude dude keep him wet keep
those knees wet baby hop in and out what
was happening but he made his first
appearance came up alright anyway dude
whatever man
don't [ __ ] guys who zero in or the
worst man every time I look at my friend
he's talking to her and he's defying
gravity the way he's leaning forward
he's like Michael Jackson in the [ __ ]
video smooth criminal' he's like doing
the [ __ ] the the lean forward and
she's defying gravity way back on her
heels
dude he'll talk to a chick for an hour
and a half
look at this oh wow oh this is the great
this is the greatest one idiot bought on
StubHub 1200 okay this is out done my
[ __ ] opener is I write tele and ride
out that that's true so then I write
both of them hey Mike your dumb huh and
then Andrew writes where are you getting
this simple that one person bought
twelve hundred tickets Mike says that's
not what I said [ __ ] I said my buddy
spent twelve hundred no didn't [ __ ] yes
I have I have [ __ ] evidence right
here this is what he said nope nope oh
dude here we go nope that's not how yes
said it exactly how he said it here
that's what you said that means only
that someone bought 1200 tickets wow
you're dumb even dumber look at how I do
it then I thought I'm not no nothing's
ever my fault oh I mean common sense man
he writes a man with two ends coming
common sense Michael man that it that is
common sense one idiot bought on StubHub
1200 that means one thing dude somebody
bought 1200 of something Wow that's it
dude now I'm pissed
yes dude everything was fine and now I'm
pissed
yes anyway do it pop in and out when
you're talking to a girl pop pop it's
boxing dude
means one thing all right dude I'm being
so respectful on you guys in take
literally texting woolum look he wrote
like if I put it no I'm not no no I'm
doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it dude
I'm not a grammar police I'm not a
grammar police man that means literally
one thing one idiot bought on StubHub
twelve hundred that means one thing if
you had said one a guy bought tickets
for twelve thousand twelve hundred
dollars that be another thing yes I'm
right yes dude if you don't text like
this if you don't sweat in your armpits
when you touch you ain't [ __ ] someone to
resell them he said like who would buy
twelve hundred tickets oh are you a
[ __ ] are you a [ __ ] elephant dude
you didn't say it was he didn't say it
was your friend you said one alright
anyway dude I'm out do it this is it I'm
gonna do this all day now yes yes yes
yes yes yes
download the catch up for free on the
App Store or Google Play market you guys
are awesome man text me eight one eight
two three nine seventy eighty seven you
got those life rips hoodies you can get
Foxwoods Bethlehem Rochester Royal Oak
and see me on all the shit's I'm gonna
be in Detroit Tampa Melbourne Florida
Hollywood El Paso Houston llúria and
Chicago Illinois all right you guys are
great thank you so much for listening
and if I row my baby
[Music]